au canada québec qu'on s'en rend pas
compte mais il ya énormément de
tourbières
la tourbière c'est un milieu qu'on
connaît pautex dans l'espèce deux arbres
de diversité biologique
parce que ça avait des espèces qui sont
nulle part ailleurs
malheureusement on a toujours la
perception que ses skis et ailleurs qui
vaut la peine d'être préservé où la
peine d'être étudiées
celle ci vous le fils qu aller au pot
c'est la troisième fois que c'est au
québec
avec le grossissement de la
macrophotographie les gens font croire
on assure chine où est probablement dans
tacot très peu de chances qu'on trouve
de nouvelles serres de mammifères
d'oiseaux au québec ça c'est très peu
probable par contre les groupes plus
négliger moins connu mais il ya encore
plein de choses à découvrir c'est pas
vrai que c'est juste dans les forêts
tropicales que les choses intéressantes
chez nous à mon avis à moi c'est aussi
intéressant
[Musique]
tpr est toujours très toujours pas mais
moi sans me
casser le spécialiste des araignées ou
québec moi je me dire en amérique du
nord mais je pense agenda vrai que je
dise ce que j'aime c'est que c'est un
violent scientifique mais il est capable
de rire agile et lui s'est décrit comme
un gars avec un kodak et puis quand tu
le connais mais c'est exactement le
contraire est un gars qui est
extrêmement professionnelle très curieux
aussi qui aime apprendre des choses et
ça ça fait une bonne combinaison
l'espèce de mariage avec une bonne
photographie une bonne documentation et
d'effets biologiques sont intéressants
je pense que c'est ce qui explique le
mieux le petit veau qui était improbable
il ya quelques années alain oblige fondé
le groupe d'eric naulleau qui font les
amateurs de tourbières et on est à 2
c'est un gros problème parce qu'elle
serait un peu de recherche qui se fait
là dessus
[Musique]
on a décidé de faire un bios inventaire
d'un endroit qui est particulier au
québec est un endroit qui est protégé
ici on est dans une tourbière à saint
denis sur richelieu ça appartient aux
sons de la nature de mont-saint-hilaire
on est à l'intérieur de la réserve de la
biosphère du mont souffle à
[Musique]
cet endroit là haut la réputation d'être
un havre de diversité mais curieusement
enfin on essaie de donner un portrait de
quelle peut être la biodiversité
maladroit et comme c'est pas possible de
tout étudié on prend quelques groupes
qu'on appelle les bio indicateurs et on
pense que les araignées vont donner un
portrait plutôt fidèle de ce qui se
passait pour la santé espèce
alors ce qu'on a ici son nom ses clio
noire et paris appellent à la curieuse
habitude de plier des brins d'herbe
comme ceux où les feuilles c'est pour
faire une espèce de petite loge dans
laquelle elle veut et va se mettre elle
va pondre ses oeufs dans la la je me
sens fermé avec ses oeufs dans la loge
toutefois je défais ici quand on joue
comme ça va être un peu gêné
une tourbière a fait c'est un menu qui
différent de la plupart des choses qu'on
connaissait pas une forêt c'est pour un
champ c'est pas non plus une friche
c'est pas un marais c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose c'est qu'au seul à
cause la composition végétale qu'il est
une espèce d'immense et punch c'est
comme un énorme filtre point de vue
qu'au système
parce que c'est un milieu particulier
parce que c'est un ph acide d'un paquet
d'animaux de plantes qui se trouve
particulièrement bien ça contient des
fragments de studio de la grande
richesse des espèces qu'on a au québec
au canada qui se trouve juste dans ces
endroits
lorsqu'on le fait on utilise un
protocole que je n'ai de la paix une
copie danic qui est capable de
quantifier c'est à dire avec une mesure
de temps précise
la végétation puisque était au sol
s'il ya beaucoup de sphaigne beaucoup de
mousse qui sont au sol c'est ce que j'ai
une très grande richesse une grande
partie de la diversité qui va être
essentiel si mosley donc avec mon ami
mais je capable a concentré d'aller la
chercher et c'est souvent les
découvertes et les choses et tout va et
c'est là dedans qu'on passe à passer
pour des choses qui sont de petite
taille des grand chose on va les arrêter
plus au battage mais c'est des choses
rares convois jamais c'est toujours dans
ses horizons donc une très très grande
richesse qui est associé au sol et plus
les sols sont complexes et plus de
chances d'avoir espèces intéressantes m
on va juste ramasser ce qu'on a besoin
pour faire nos preuves
le premier déjà ici
un des objectifs qu'on s'est fixés comme
humanité du moins en principe c'est de
pas perdre c'est aussi faire en sorte
que notre activité bien pas éliminer un
paquet de choses qui étaient vivantes
sur notre planète c'est un bon principe
mais l'appliquer c'est quelque chose qui
est plus difficile surtout quand on
connaît pas très bien ce qui est légal
ans donc ce qu'on essaie de faire ici
c'est au moins documentés met un point
dans le tech dentelle amis ici dans cet
endroit là on sait que telle ou telle
espèce et avec les protocoles qui ont
fait qu'on a mis au point qu'on utilise
bien ce serait possible de les
scientifiques dans 50 ans rafa c'est
exactement la même chose qui puisse voir
est ce que c'est vrai qu'on a perdu des
espèces est ce que c'est vrai qu'au
québec on en compte - quel
goût ça j'essaie cigares et les licences
artistique
c'est probablement la première fois au
monde que ces vues le domaine
c'est la de la médaille ce qui est
spécialisé dans les tourbières ps
posément rares parlement que séparent du
tout c'est juste que c'est dans l'étau
bien foutu et cherche la pouponnière à
français est restée très discrète
beaucoup plus que ce qu'on pense pas
qu'on en avait cherché n'avait pas
trouvé meilleur vient de trouver
pourquoi on n'y trouvait pas sans trop
de ce qu'est une centaine de petits qui
sont sortis de toute beauté face à carl
howe elles sont toutes là mais
malheureusement la maman est sortie
ouais c'est vrai bien intervention de
documenter sont très contents bourse
lorsque je veux faire c'est du battage
c'est à dire que c'est dans notre
protocole c'est une des techniques ou
est ce qu'on va chercher
les avanies qui sont au dessus de ça je
croise de temps à aucune assuré que ça
descend dans le pot qu'on voit en
dessous
au départ je suis vraiment un
naturaliste quelqu'un amoureux de la
nature un amoureux du monde vivant
une des activités de ce que j'aime faire
c'est le joaillier dans un milieu comme
la tombe bien où je m'assume à soi et
j'attends
au bout de quatre cinq minutes ça
commence à bouger autour de moi
[Musique]
il ya des cinqs que du bruit car il y
avait bien des abeilles il ya des cas
les apps tard au sol sam aux gens que ça
bougeait beaucoup beaucoup de vip
moi j'avais le goût de partager cette
merveille mal j'avais le goût de
partager ce que moi je ressens quand je
suis dans un environnement comme ça que
j'ai trouvé le plus accessible pour moi
c'était d'utiliser la photographie
[Musique]
abu
mingar à ses
fils de
celle-ci vous le fil à quoi les os x
c'est la troisième fois que c'est au
québec la deuxième c'était gentil si
l'année passée là on en a trop bien à
trouver trop tôt car c'est l'abondance
on a notre 2 qui ont jamais été vu au
canada qui ont été trouvés à la
tourbière pour la première fois on a
notre roi de mémoire qu'elle ait jamais
été trouvées au québec on a une qui
avait probablement été jamais vu par
aucun humain et ce serait peut-être la
plus petite araignée au canada quand on
parle de points 5 mm pour les adultes on
devrait avoir une réponse là dessus
bientôt mais pas la plus belle
découverte pour la
bonne récolte félicitations mon cher
bateau au dessus on s'en rend chez nous
oui on a des photos après pièce
[Musique]
ces boues sont dessinés sur son dos sont
un peu nerveux
mais
évidemment bouge tous mes canons
ok c'est déjà moins haut ça semble très
très bon
c'est quand on la voit ne renvoie on
voit bien qu une petite ligne rouge en
arrière mais on devait réussir sur ce
poste ce boxeur
[Musique]
a fait on vient voir à quoi ressemblent
pour vrai
[Musique]
la contribution que la photographie
d'insectes apa est absolument
renversante ça emmène chez les gens
ressentent d'émerveillement je vois ça à
tous les jours des gens qui disent je
trouve un seul et avant où je mets pas
ça ou ça me faisait pas puis maintenant
je trouve sur admirable je trouve ça
beau j'en reviens pas c'est rendu que
moi même j'aime les insectes on protège
ce hack on est attaché ce qu'on y tient
on s'identifie saisi que de l'émotion
qu'elle ya de l'émerveillement qu'est le
[Musique]
hockey c'est qu'on en ait fini avec
celle là je te gère mais pour que tu
l'identifier au binoculaire série b en
d3 cassé
[Musique]
chez les araignées pour identifier les
réunit c'est assez surprenant tout se
perd dans les organes génitaux les morts
ils ont une espèce de petite structure à
l'avant qui ressemble à une petite paire
de gants de boxe et chaque espèce
d'araignée sur terre à une forme de
petits gants de boxe comme ça chez les
femmes est une espèce de plaques et au
niveau de l'abdomen donc quand tu fais
une identification se regardent ces
structures là et on compare avec ce qui
est connu dans la littérature l'autre
est capable d'être certaine de quelle
espèce il s'agit
[Musique]
si tu me disais que demain matin on va
raser ça pour un faire un autre centre
de chat ou un autre stationnement c'est
pas tellement ça que l'humanité où la
société québécoise a besoin c'est
beaucoup plus des endroits qui vont être
les témoins de ce conte ainsi qu'ils
vivent il faut comprendre que la
biodiversité n'existe pas d'inverser la
protection des habitats comme ici dans
le sud du québec on en trouve presque
pour des tourbières comme ceux-ci faut
absolument conserver son
[Musique]